everybody man this is going to be the
funnest night we've been to Atlanta
she's in the Denver we've been in New
York City looking for the best battlers
in the country for our second tournament
the finals are going to be in January
maybe we'll find some of those people
tonight Joe's head is so big his mom had
a c-section and it's still destroyed her
you know I caught Alex a douche
bag but a douche bag can hold moisture
yes really I have eczema my skin is so
pink tight and wrinkled I'm amazed Joe's
not trying to funk it right now
[Applause]
you're a weirdo in that very
obviously okay all right
but here's the deal though what sold me
is what you got him and then he turned
it around back on you eat kind of eight
miles in a little bit in a way so I
gotta go without just based on that I
gotta go I thought Alex's callbacks were
on point tonight and Alex never
wins in the pity ball is the first time
- no I meant in wife robbery yesterday
are we good guy you look like a Jeff
Ross beanbag chair
[Applause]
tibarn
you're so hot but you're so ghetto and
uneducated I never know whether I should
you or try to teach you Shakespeare
through hip-hop Pat just lost his job at
HBO writing for Bill Simmons you finally
got an hour from HBO it was to clean out
your desk speaking of speaking of Robin
really wants a sexchange and I really
hope that it happened four it'll give
president Trump something to grab to
throw her out of the country last joke
joke
he's the fat bisexual so you could
his neck his back his and his crap
[Applause]
absolutely true like I go both ways just
like Ana's shitty tits honestly I think
Anna's just jealous because my parents
get to watch the battle on TV and herds
have to watch from wherever Mexicans go
instead of heaven
I mean you had the first were you where
she said something Anna do you
brought it back to everything she did
the same thing it was like volleyball
they were great and great battle all
right without okay we went a vote
how would you like do you like World
Peace I think when he said how boos were
different directions I think that was
Paul she has great boobs but
I'll you know you're in
the NBA right there's so many more boobs
for you